(audience applauds)
All righty, everybody.
It's time for Drew's News,
your bottomless bucket of good news popcorn shrimp.
Yum yum.
Oh, yum.
Dip.
One more, mm
Delish.
Always like 20 more.
And then with me at the desk
is my number one news bud, Rossy Ross Matthews.
Hi everybody.
(audience cheers)
Hi.
Pass me that shrimp.
Rossy, will you kick us off with some newsy?
I absolutely will.
Okay, first up, do you guys remember that movie,
"13 going on 30"?
Yes!
Okay.
It will go down in the rom com hall of fame for sure.
And BuzzFeed reports it's stars,
Jennifer Garner and Mark Ruffalo,
they are back together, on screen,
in the new movie, "The Adam Project".
Oh, I love this.
(audience cheers)
Look at that.
(audience applauds)
And so they're out for that.
They're doing some press
and they just revealed they'd both be down
for a Matty and Jenna comeback for a sequel,
and Jennifer Garner joked
"It could be called 50 going on 80". (laughs)
But I think that's the perfect movie for a reboot,
because it's like, for starters,
it's underrated, don't you think?
[Audience Members] Yeah.
And we saw them when they were 13 and 30,
now, they're what, are they like 40, mid-forties?
And they'd probably have kids by now,
you know what I mean?
Yes.
I wanna see what their kids
would be dreaming up in their thirties, you know?
Well, I literally quote that movie every day of my life.
I love that movie so much.
I've watched it for years,
my daughters love it.
It's a real classic
and it has not only stood the test of time,
I think it gets better with each year.
More and more people just appreciate it.
It's the best.
I would totally love.
(audience applauds)
Love.
And I love when movies have that staying power,
you know what I mean?
It does.
It has classic staying power,
just gets better and better and better.
Well, next up.
I wanna talk about going to bed.
Oh.
How delicious is it,
at the end of the day,
to put on your coziest and softest PJs
and dive right into bed,
snug as a bug in a rug?
Well, now the question is,
do you also own a set of "the good pajamas"?
Southern Living reports that
if you have no idea what that means,
you must not be from the south.
A pair of good pajamas is a fresh matching set of PJs
that you reserve for special occasions.
Hmm. What would that be?
Let's say a vacation with friends
or your first sleepover at the in-laws house.
(audience laughs)
Ross?
(laughs) Yes?
What are your favorite PJs?
And do you have the good pajamas?
Do you have them on reserve?
Do you have 'em on tap?
What's your PJ game?
Well, I, okay, thank you for asking, I'm...
I really don't know what your PJ game is.
We've discussed a lot,
but we've never discussed our PJs before.
I know.
Listen, I did not grow up fancy,
so my pajamas are always old sweats.
It wasn't until adulthood
that I had grown up pajamas and now I'm into it.
I am.
So what do you wear at night, Rossy?
Thank you so much. Ah-ha.
Well, I love-
(audience laughs)
I could talk about this all day.
I love, I didn't know that I loved pajamas this much
until Wellington, who's a pajama person.
He has multiple sets, that are like fancy grandma pajamas.
And so now, I get home.
And the first thing I do is I'm like,
"Hi, hi, gotta go."
I'm elastic, head to toe.
You know what I mean?
Mm-hm.
And I have a pair of,
my favorite one is cashmere,
(Drew gasps)
which is fancy, I know.
We got it on, calm down, we got it on sale, all right?
(audience laughs)
It was a clearance pajama,
but it's like, it's my go-to.
Okay, now I gotta ask,
is your little tushy next to the cashmere?
Or do you wear undies?
How does it work?
'Cause if I see cashmere, I'm gonna wanna go commando.
Is that weird? (exasperates in embarrassment)
I'd like to speak to HR.
I'm feeling,
(audience laughs)
I'm feeling very uncomfortable.
(audience applauds)
(Ross laughs)
I'm gonna lock myself in on underwear, all right?
I wear underwear with my...
I mean, I wear underwear.
I'm wearing underwear right now,
but sometimes I'm like, I don't want anything touching me.
I sleep in the nude, a lot.
Oh, never.
(audience whoops)
Oh really?
No. I would never sleep in the nude, ever, ever, ever.
Okay.
Who here would never sleep in the nude?
Me.
(audience laughs)
Right!
There's a couple.
I'm sorry, but my-
Kyle. (laughs)
My luck would be the one night I tried it,
there'd be a fire in the house,
or something, the alarm would go off and I'd be out front.
That's why you need a head lip on your bedside table.
Wait, okay, you are the only one with Rossy.
What is your name and why would you never wear nothing?
My name is Matthew and I just feel uncomfortable.
(all laughing)
Yeah. I'm with you.
But what about if you're intimate with someone?
Do you then put clothes on to pass out?
Or is it okay, if you're with somebody?
Well, this is my boyfriend and he sleeps nude
but I just don't like it.
(all laugh)
I totally get it.
(audience applauds)
Yeah.
Well I'm with you.
I love sleeping in the nude.
I love it so much.
What do you love about it?
Air it out!
(audience laughs)
Just don't, like...
Air it out?
Yes.
My God.
You don't air out...
You air out a dusty old sheet, not...
You know what I'm saying?
(audience laughs)
It's like the weirdest combo.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
We're, apparently...
Guess what? It's our mirror image couple.
Right there, there we are!
Cute.
Something for everyone.
Thank you, guys.
(bright music)